israel and the palestinian territories
are going up in
flames after years of relative peace
during the trump administration but do
not worry
because president biden has things under
control he has sent his spokesman out
to kindly and politely tell people to
please
de-escalate since last week he has
directed his team to engage intensively
with senior israeli and palestinian
officials as well as leaders throughout
the middle east
his team is communicating a clear and
consistent message
in support of de-escalation and that is
our primary focus
that's good that's what does it that's
what brings peace to the middle east is
a clear and consistent message
from the team of the president to
de-escalate even though the president's
own messaging
on his support for israel's enemies has
been a little bit
inconsistent which has probably led us
to this very
very moment what is going on in israel
i don't know how much time do we have we
could we could be here for a very long
time
a lot of news outlets are going really
really really in-depth
on exactly what started the conflict and
the left-wing outlets are saying the
israelis started this and the
right-wing outlets are saying it was the
palestinian arabs and
it was because of this and it was
because of that and you could spend a
whole lot of time going back through the
millennia
to to find the origin of of this
particular conflict
for our purposes what is relevant today
is the timing why is this breaking out
right now
why were things relatively cool under
the trump administration but now they've
gotten a lot hotter
under the biden administration it's
because of two competing approaches to
the middle east
when john kerry was secretary of state
before he was gallivanting all over the
world trying to stop the sun monster
john kerry said that there is no way
to bring peace to the middle east
without first solving
the palestinian problem what is the
palestinian problem well you got this
country
israel which is created in 1948 and
you've got arabs
that are in the region and then you've
got national borders being said all
around and then
you've got this group of people that the
other countries don't want
and that are holding out hope that they
can get rid of israel entirely
and this has created violence and and
violence has ebbed and flowed over the
years why
again i there is no reason to go
any more in depth on that that way lies
madness
the the thing that matters for us right
now is why were things relatively
peaceful under trump
and why were they why are they getting
more violent under biden
because donald trump sent a clear
message he said the united states is not
going to tolerate attacks
on the existence of israel we're not
going to give
money to people who hate us in the
region
and we're not going to side with iran
why is this well very famously i
remember seeing them when i was
when i was 11 years old the image is on
september 11th
of palestinian arabs dancing in the
streets if you want the support of the
united states it's not a good idea to
dance in the streets in celebration
when the world trade center is attacked
so
they're but even beyond the palestinian
arabs there are
lots of places in this region that don't
like us very much notably iran
the democrats strategy on the middle
east was
suck up to iran and suck up to the
palestinian arabs
and if you focus on the palestinian
issue that will solve the middle east
the right took a completely different
approach
donald trump said john kerry you're
wrong you don't need to solve this
palestinian issue you're not going to
solve this palestinian issue so we're
going to go directly to the actual
nation states in the middle east
because don't forget palestine is not a
country it's that country east of
wakanda and left of narnia right it's
not
there is no nation state there called
palestine so go to the other places and
you'll get peace deals this is what
happened
and iran is a big issue here the obama
administration
biden want to send pallets of cash to
iran the trump administration kills
iran's top general
right different friends different allies
different approach to the middle east
which one worked out better we we have
the data
we've got the evidence things were much
more stable
much more peaceful under trump but that
is not stopping democrats
from going back to the same old failed
strategy
bernie sanders tweets that the united
states must call for an immediate
ceasefire and an end to provocative and
illegal settlement activity
and we must also recommit to working
with israelis and palestinians
to finally end this conflict i think
most people
are going to first of all they're going
to read this tweet and say that bernie
sanders is blaming israel here right
uh okay but they're gonna they're gonna
read this tweet and they're gonna say
what do i care what do i care as an
american about israel and palestine and
the middle east why do we have to be
there at all what is the point of this
why is our foreign policy dominated
by this one region of the world and they
have a good point
the american foreign policy should be
pretty simple do what is in the interest
of the united states
right seems simple enough now this gets
complicated because
we are involved in lots of world affairs
and we have
alliances and we are dependent on
certain places and
we it matters to us if one power gets
too big and we want to suppress other
powers so
i'm not saying it's as simple as put
your head in the sand and hope that
everything is okay in the middle east
but if our foreign policy is to do what
is in the interest of the united states
then it would seem very much to be in
our interest
to keep things relatively stable over
there without having to send troops
without having to really get involved in
any wars
when wars break out people have to start
taking sides people have to start
getting involved
and the fact is the simple fact is that
the policy of
legitimizing the palestinian nation
state
led to more violence dragged america
into this issue much much further
and the policy of basically ignoring the
palestinian
palestinian claims for a nation state
and just going directly to our other
friends and allies in the middle east
going to other arab states in the region
and saying hey
make peace don't be a jerk keep things
calm we're going to be back over here on
the other side of the atlantic
that seemed to work out pretty well so
perhaps we should do
more of that but of course joe biden
the liberal establishment the broad sort
of liberal
imperialist foreign policy types they
don't want that
stop collaborate and listen collaborate
with me
by ringing that bell like and subscribe
otherwise
you're just not going to get
notifications for these videos frankly
even if you do you might not get
notifications because our overlords here
at
youtube are not not always so happy with
me but the best way to have a chance of
knowing when our new content comes out
is to ring that bell do it today
see you next time
[Music]
you